dans un exercice de communication que
l'on pourra qualifier de théâtral c'est
devant les caméras et les journalistes
que joe biden a relevé sa manche ce
lundi pour se faire injecter une
troisième doses de vaccins une preuve
par l'exemple selon la maison blanche de
la nécessité pour les personnes
concernées d'y recourir l'occasion aussi
pour joe biden de réitérer ses appels à
destination de la population américaine
écouter mais
laissez moi être clair les rappels sont
importants mais la chose la plus
importante que nous devons faire est de
faire vacciner plus de gens la grande
majorité des américains font ce qu'il
faut plus de 77 % des adultes se sont
fait vacciner au moins une fois environ
23 % n'ont pas été vaccinés et cette
minorité distinctes dérange beaucoup
d'entre nous cause beaucoup de dommages
au reste du pays c'est une pandémie de
non vaccination c'est pourquoi je vais
de l'avant avec des exigences de
vaccination partout je peux
annoncer à la dernière minute c'est
cette injection du président des états
unis avait aussi pour but de clarifier
la situation autour de cette fameuse
troisième injection initialement le
gouvernement américain espérait lancer
une campagne de rappel pour l'ensemble
de la population américaine sauf qu'un
comité consultatif de l'agencé
américaine des médicaments la f10 s y
est opposé limitant cette troisième
injection seulement pour les personnes
âgées de plus de 65 ans quelques jours
plus tard la si d'ici le centre de lutte
contre les maladies ici aux etats-unis
s'étaient également prononcés contre et
contre cette fois le recours à une
troisième injection pour les personnes
fréquemment exposés au virus de par leur
profession alors finalement la chef de
l'aci dc a décidé de passer outre cette
recommandation du comité d'experts pour
étendre donc ce qu'on appelle ici le
booster shot à cette catégorie de la
population alors ces annonces
contradictoires ont semé la confusion
auprès des américains alors aujourd'hui
sont concernés par cette troisième
injection les personnes de plus de 65
ans les personnes de plus de 18 ans
ayant des risques de comorbidité tels
que l'obésité
au diabète et puis enfin les personnes
dont le travail les expose d'une manière
assez fréquentes à des possibilités de
contamination 60 millions d'américains
sont donc éligibles à cette troisième
injection de vaccin dont un tiers déjà a
atteint le délai des six mois nécessaire
entre la deuxième et la troisième
injection alors ses campagnes de rappel
on sont critiqués par l' oms qui estime
que la priorité doit être donnée à une
meilleure répartition des vaccins dans
le monde plutôt qu'à une troisième dose
interrogé à ce sujet joe biden a
expliqué que les deux combats n'étaient
pas incompatibles selon lui